bring bring the relaxation into your
lower legs as well
Tristan good on the arms lower legs as
well more and more keep keep striving
for more relaxation in the lower
legs
so his feet are turned outward there's
no way he's midfoot Vector what what's
he weighted where's he weighted feet
turned out where he'll weighted you see
and yet we have a similar result again
that the UK is a tool here not a
choreographed Dr Pony okay come in get
your ground Vector asuk Center this
place and then whatever happens happens
don't don't come in to go out okay
go
okay you're giving yourself a backf foot
bracing angle did you
see whoa you actually
tremedous you
go and you leaned forward right that's a
bracing angle too right
okay
good and bring it down to your lower
legs lower
legs
all right do do you uh feel tension
coming into your body as you try to do
it okay and that that's the point of the
drill is uh to bring awareness to that
tension
okay
um here the tension won't serve you here
in this drill the tension is going to
make you go backwards right uh because
that tension is from a
dichotomist worldview and they have all
the inertia the bracing angle uh their
action and you tend to either have
nothing because they
stopped or uh you get pushed back does
that make sense okay whereas in the in
the other
ones
you you get your back foot like you
wanted a back foot you see and that
means I'm probably using my back foot is
a bracing angle without realizing it
okay do you guys get that okay
so um some of some of the
more advanced in this skill your arms
are relaxed which is really good you got
to start there um but the legs are still
have some you still go whoa and you
still hold that and there's flexion in
through the in through the glutes okay
and down through the lower legs um okay
why because that's where you feel the
dichotomy but subjectively you're
experiencing as I'm not going to make it
or they're going to get me do you see
that it's very it's an egocentricity
that happens and it is concentric with
that flexion so you have to bring some
awareness to the flexion to identify the
problem and then you have to do the
remedy and the remedy is is uh self-
Detachment
okay any questions on
that so as I'm trying to do this drill I
try to release release all the way down
just release
release I'll feel that come in right
here I felt it do you see or I release
it and I get reps that release
it's not so much that I'm in a released
State and I I want to do that I want to
kind of get myself then I release that
get myself in trouble
release get myself in trouble trouble
release you guys see how I'm doing that
and it's kind of scary cuz you're
like and then I release
it okay let's let's see but let's have
you try that I think most of you will
get in trouble and be bounced off
because the antagonism shows up but
maybe a couple of you can get in trouble
release and you'll get that skill which
is the skill you want which is the
releasing skill because the ego Tri
partti mind never goes away it's always
there and we need that skill to be able
to balance out the two minds do you guys
understand all right let's see what
we
often times we'll look at
that and we're going to think it's a
physical problem but it's it's not a
physical problem it's a mind problem
okay so yes I do Flex yeah but and yes
that's physiology but I'm flexing
because I'm antagonistically
experiencing the relationship and that
is not a physical problem that's a mind
problem okay and then it concentrically
manifests physiologically do do you guys
understand okay so for example as as
he's coming in and you're like I'm in
trouble get you might be thinking I'm in
trouble cuz I lean back here no no no
I'm in trouble because I had that mind
so you as you're free you could
do
never in trouble do do you understand
that do you get that I know it's weird
because you're like wait where is that
where's the anatomical positioning but
that's what had you in these bracing
angles and the skeletal alignment in the
first place you see but you if you don't
ever have that antagonism you could be
in weird ass places weird
and it'll it's going to work okay like
very do you
see
that should not be
doable got do you understand okay so um
it's really in the mind that's why I
said the solution is to continue working
your self- Detachment practices because
this can be one but even in the practice
of it
I'm I'm kind of like got in trouble oh I
shouldn't even be thinking about this
okay and here's here's why so let's say
I'm
doing aido okay Kon Wasa and you could
see there's a skeletal alignment is is
really what I'm using even though I
don't have the obvious A-frame it's
still a bracing angle here it's a
different feeling you see it's a
different feeling when you're doing
doing it right it look it kind I think
anyone that can knows what to look for
would see the high glute the tension in
the lower leg and the the need for that
skeletal alignment even in the in the
way that the uh L the the pseudo L lon's
face is uh I'm sorry is constructed so
you're like this you see as opposed to
your your these metacarpal are opening
okay and so it's it's a different
feeling and so it does different things
to the person as you're moving
around okay
so let us realize
why we want to get away from a skeletal
alment okay spiritually it's
antagonistic so spiritually it's fear
based it's ego triar mind based and we
want to realize the difficult difficulty
in identifying where we're doing it
because there's a lot of people that
will think I'm not I'm not antagonistic
do you see I'm blending and know from
the get-go you're not
okay and then we want to understand what
can we do with that stuff well I think
it's pretty cool that you could do
whatever you want with it versus I have
to be in a perfect place every time and
the posture has to be
this and not that okay uh and in
particular we're going to focus in on
the shoulder okay the shoulder is key so
in terms of
fighting uh because most of the personal
weapons or artifacts that I use as
Weapons they're in my hands you're going
to find that the shoulder because it's a
ball and socket joint is a weak point in
how well you can deliver Force into your
hands
okay and you're also going to find
though that it's
psychologically it's a point that we
once we realize that it's a marshall
weak point we we lock it in place do you
see and now you're doing all your iido
like this kind of stuff which makes whoa
that's going to feel way weird to you're
not going to be able to do okay so let
us go back
to uh
um the inward outward spiral and pay
attention you have you have to come
closest okay so the inward outward
spiral drill again is this one Bo it
comes back
in boom okay you I I want all of you you
do that drill to learn the pattern first
you have to learn the gross pattern you
have to learn the gross pattern okay and
then you're going to go deep and deeper
to where you get to this spiritual
training where am I doing this
antagonistically am I doing it bracing
angle so you see you go like
this see and if you pay attention you're
like going to go I I know I'm using
them okay and I would
say that there's a lot of shoulder
injuries in iido for an art that is not
supposed to be using his shoulders okay
just it's like there's a lot of knee
injuries in the art that's supposed to
be doing
Chico uh why because we're antagonistic
even with our choreographed ukz
okay so when you do this drill you want
to again go to the physiology do you
feel like you're using your shoulder
okay do you feel like you need the
bracing angle all right and you're going
to have to get to that spiritual level
and I'm going to bring it back to the
shoulder which is not always uh
observable and I'm not sure it'll show
up here okay so when you do your spiral
your inward
spiral if you do it like this you're
going to you should feel it here that's
incorrect okay so you come around and
you're doing it you're doing bracing
angle okay and you're going to you
should as you get to the top you
actually feel that outer deltoid
Activation so what you have to do to do
the EM spiral is you're going to take
the
locked the lockness or the locked
shoulder that you're using and you have
to drop it okay and you're going to see
that that shoulder is
moving you see that is it
visible okay on this side your shoulder
is going to move so I don't leave that
there
and then turn if you did you you will
feel it here and he can actually push
down on me as I can't support that
there's a movement where your shoulder
breaks that connection so Tristan come
here so you can feel
it just put a finger on there okay and
here I leave it in space and you could
even you should be able to feel those
muscles flexed I leave it locked in
space and you feel those muscles okay
what I'm going to do is that you feel
that that
right okay and that's actually what
brings the UK into the y space that's
why the UK you see my UK always go whoa
their body comes this there's no way
they can come forward if I leave the
shoulder locked and I'm here but if I
make the shoulder go back you see then
he comes he can come in okay and so
there is a kind
of and you start looking at the the
whole body
now and look at my watch my
hand you can see oh damn that thing's
moving which you were said all along
okay so I move
it and then guess what it's going to
move
back
boom so now when you're doing this drill
instead of doing it like
[Music]
this you're more in your shoulder
releasing the
shoulder
okay got it and and why would you be
doing that well martially I should make
things smaller always they require less
time less space uh but uh spiritually
I'm not in an antagonistic relationship
energetically I can release the shoulder
because I'm working with rebounding Yang
energy or aspect and I'm not working
with a skeletal alignment okay so again
I don't get into oh
I
release
and that is going to feel like trouble
to you do you see but we already know
that it's not it's not trouble to me
okay
[Music]
you want more energy it comes from your
body Your Body
Move
so I just
comef and I just want you to be able to
feel when you feel that un unlock okay
I'll do one
side push
hard
Can you feel it it's not going to be
here and I
move like a robot okay and so if you're
doing uh you're doing NY you move like a
robot he's going to stay out there you
see and he pushes and you release the
shoulder he comes
in if you're doing a
CLE you see you're going to have to try
to get him back but he's here and you
use that
shoulder again brings him in it's the I
adhesion and he's going forward for the
back break F so there's a lot of that
but it's lost in iido because
psychologically I'm antagonistic to my
my UK why cuz I'm fear based and as a
result I seek skeletal
alignment which is
unnatural try the inward outward
spiral so do you feel how you don't want
to do it
okay
and that one didn't do it at
all so at least we can tell like oh I
feel like I'm going to get weak if I do
it and then on the second one we're not
doing that at all okay at least we're
bringing awareness to it all right Sean
you're going
so you left your shoulders locked and
turned your waist so we don't want to do
it at all right well you have a lot of
classic iido training right and that's
what that's the
aesthetic is we look like we're in the
tension and we keep those shoulders
locked okay you got to try something
different to be something
different whoa
that is a lot of inner deltoid he let's
go through just keep
going and again we're not seeing it on
the
outside whoa you we just moving our arm
in
space all right let's get some detail
so think about Marley when it should
happen so I gave you two two uh
catalysts to to measure by so for
example um it's got to be where when I
release it he can come in so if I
release it he came in a little but he's
not going into the P you got it so the
shoulder I'm going to keep it here and
it's actually when you would feel that
ah that delto is out that's where I
released it
okay so you just like all things
complete the Yang cycle of action and
right when you feel that n that's going
to Yong Yong Clash that's when you
release it okay and when you release it
that's the turn happens on its own so
don't don't do it like
this okay he's pressing oh there a lot
of pressure you see okay I started it's
going to now I'll start going there and
that's when I dropped that shoulder
okay that's so I'm giving you some
Clues it's not just open up and get that
outer deltoid
okay and when you do do what you've been
doing and then when you start to feel
that don't ignore that that's going to
be a clash that's where you drop that
drop the shoulder release the shoulder
however you want to describe it and
that's where the rest of the Spiral
happens okay
on the out the outer
one he comes around okay he he might
Sometimes some ukas get here like
they're on the adhesion and it's easier
to feel
um but as you come around here boom you
don't want to start pushing here okay
here is where the the extra
drop does that part and then cool he's
there
okay what mostly happens is we just make
a big circle with our arm and come
around but you should feel it again in
that outer deltoid so let's look at the
big
circle big circle look how my shoulders
stay still do you
see and watch how wide the hand and is
to the outer
rim okay now watch my elbow in the big
circle big
circle it is making a circle at the same
time that my hand is that my shoulder is
cuz I'm just doing this do you see that
all right on the other
one it's
not you see
they're they're kind of snaking so if we
can NOP here big circle one big lever
like a stick in this one do you see the
shoulder has circled the hand has not
shoulder elbow hand okay not not a big
thing like that okay so again he's
pushing hard pushing hard pushing hard
your hardest your absolute
hardest your absolute hardest
sh
okay so I don't want to have on the
outer one one big stick with my elbow
shoulder and hand and the same uh radius
there that's shoulder elbow hand okay
wom and then what do you think it's the
other way too shoulder elbow Head okay
on this one
shoulder this is where you would get the
adhesion You' bring them forward there
right into the elbow and then this comes
up and out on the Emi right it's when
you go shoulder elbow that's when he
comes in there and then on this grip
that's where the coou projection is on
that grip okay all right let's let's see
if we can not
have this these stick circles do you see
there this
circle okay even if it's gross like I'm
doing now you see I'm showing I'm trying
to show it to you guys do you think you
need to show it you don't need to show
it okay you don't you don't in fact as
your skill goes higher the movement is
smaller and shorter and therefore there
shouldn't be this big body movement it's
just inside of you that you're doing it
okay so we have some gross movements
here to work with okay here we
go so you have that stick you're moving
on the outward spiral and then you just
have bracing angle on the inward even
your left leg move backwards as it got
displaced
okay yeah see you feel like I'm not
going to unlock that shoulder okay but
that's what we're working on hey
in in my
teachings the dichotomous mind is the
ego tripartite mind
so and I have simplified it to it's just
uh it's Yi it's Earth aspect it is uh
fear it is demonic it's half of the
universe
okay
um and so it would include of course
things like ah myuk ah I'm going to fail
in my technique but it would also
include the desire to do the technique
okay and I'm still seeing that on the
outward spiral so when you
now throw like like that do you see do
you get it you again are going to
martially you're going to go back to
that outer deltoid so what I would like
for you to do is have have your hand
up and uh just drop it without feeling
that outer deltoid okay like at the 90
can you all do that so here and you're
trying to like okay just I don't want to
activate that shoulder okay it kind of
works okay and now see how far you can
go
back without activating that outer
deltoid you see and it's somewhere
around here if I start going past that
you're going to oh I already feel it I
already feel it do you see so you have
your 90 I don't feel it and I can go a
little bit more than the 90
okay well I go a lot past that 90 and
I'm way out here you should feel it okay
so your desire to throw
him you're you're all fine here and then
you got you and you're like here
and you triggered it again remember
these are energetic
exercises that are designed to drop the
mind what what or or that's a a
traditional understanding drop the mind
the Mind drops okay um I say you're
you're bringing a sensation to the ego
tripartite mind but when you desire to
throw you reactivate the mind
okay
um traditionally why it's called
dropping the mind again as I've said
before I myself and I don't think anyone
can but I'm not done learning I don't
think you can just distinguish Chief
from
mind I'm not saying they're the same
thing I just can't tell what's what any
any perception I have of chi is a mind
is mind perception do do you understand
that so you do Chi does drop but the
Mind drops too okay you feel you'll feel
that so I I'm cool with the with the uh
traditional phrase the Mind drops the
tree drop you will feel that when the
ego tripartite mind the dichotomous
experience of the world ceases things
just drop okay uh and I literally mean
down there's a sensation of w okay um so
when you come back here and you could
tell that those that were doing it all
of a sudden who you come back up and you
could see your your ego tripartite mind
Consciousness come back into your face
your body your hands all that kind of
stuff okay so just remember uh as you're
doing this stuff that I can only drop
there do you get it cuz what I want is
to keep that
sensation of the mind dropping the chi
dropping do do you understand that I
don't really care what he does I care
how I'm doing it okay and so the reason
why I ask him to push his hardest is
it's more likely to
trigger everything I don't want trigger
so it's a higher training environment
okay so he'll push his absolute hardest
and I'll do the drill with and I don't
really pay
attention so if you look if you look at
my hand it's here do you see it doesn't
go over here what I'm chasing is the
dropped mind I'm not
chasing
eor and khole and throw tayor do do do
you guys understand that I'm chasing the
drop mind and the symptomologies of that
mind relaxation free shoulder go do you
understand that
effortlessness it it doesn't matter so
you're over here and this is another
thing that I said you push this angle
this angle is going to be push push your
hard there you go
okay as I said when you're in that state
you're not using bracing angles and yet
it's working so this is why he can he
can push on this angle here and it
doesn't matter because once I'm in that
state he doesn't do
anything it does not affect
me
you get it and so just more evidence
that bracing angles skeletal alignment
uh posture even like you have to have
good
posture is really not on the mark okay
instead chase the mine which to me is
more important I'm not I don't really
care if I can do those techniques I
don't care if you rank me because I can
do those techniques I don't care if I
defend myself with those techniques it
is more valuable that I can learn to
drop the Mind drop the chi and go ahead
and experience the world without this
antagonism or this dichotomy so don't
Chuck them okay everything's looking
good on some of you and then you go like
yeah iido okay no keep keep the
Mind keep the Mind CH keep the mind okay
all right try it
[Music]
again don't throw
them
[Music]
switch rolls
M yeah you got to let it go where else
is it going to
go
[Music]
it was interesting right before we
transitioned to this uh aspect of the
class where we started talking about the
releas and were transition this from
what we were doing before to what we're
doing now it's interesting to feel the
fear come up without even partnered up
without even at the prospect of having
to let go
yeah and attempt something different
yeah it was terrifying yeah it is it
really is and I don't I think not enough
people acknowledge it and then you have
even larger majority that are even aware
of it you see um and then an an even
greater majority who like I don't know
what to do about that I don't have a
solution to it to get it so I think
those are all important steps align
yourself with a solution to it uh become
aware of the problem be honest about the
problem and then start applying the
solution to the best of your ability
okay what I what I'm trying to do uh any
other other questions that's a great
point and I can see you doing that I can
see you working through it
and
what remember the pointer I gave you is
feel the feel start sensing for that
down that M drop that CH drop you're
you're going to have some physiological
symptoms of it but the main one is who
it just feels like I don't know what the
hell that is I don't know what that is
and don't try to don't try to analyze it
it's the fascia who gives a okay
the mind will drop tension will release
from the body the abdomen the lower
tonden will start swelling um you'll
calm down you'll reach this kind of
ecstatic State you I gave you other
symptomologies it doesn't matter what
Vector you're being pressed from it all
is internalized everything just goes
down
okay uh I want to give you
another way of telling again this this
is weird Okay but it should have been
weird that he can't push me and he can't
push me
okay it would it's not weird if he's
pushing me from the back because he's
pushing me into him okay all right so
another weird one
is if he can't push me and he can't push
me then I'm not pushable it's and the
way that I describe this is the energy
is being internalized the energy is
being internalized it's coming into me
um and likewise if I go so let me I only
he can feel it but I want you to feel it
okay so that's one relationship and then
here is what I'm draw you see even the
skin starts to move there is movement
but people can't can't sense it okay but
that is where the chi dropped the Mind
dropped okay and the more I talk it's
difficult because language is ego Tri
partite mind and so if you're sensitive
enough it's back off right now as I'm
talking do you see uh and I'll drop it
again there we're dropped again okay um
if he pulls on me it doesn't it's not
going to change anything nothing's going
to change okay so he's pulling now which
is the opposite of
him maybe I'm getting out of the way do
you see but he's he's trying to pull and
he'll feel the ground too okay and I'll
do the same he's pulling the same way it
doesn't matter and he's going to pull
again you see he's going to pull
again
does
do you guys see that so what that
telling you is
that CQ and II at the higher state is
indistinguishable and you can you you
are going to uh explain that several
ways so one way is saying they're
simultaneously there or they they have
disappeared and I'm in a wui state now I
both can't be displaced disrupted
because of the PO you but he's stuck and
I can make any technique work I don't
have to match the external yin to Yong
the only reason I have to match external
yin to yangong is because I can't
internalize the energy and reconcile you
Yong inside my body get it which is why
you start seeing the bracing angles okay
CU you have to overcome the the Yang
aspect to some degree and which is why
you see a Yin an external Yin yield
which is not martially unsound but if
you can only do it then it's not right
just like if I can only stop you from
displacing me through skeletal alignment
it's not right okay so here that
shoulder movement is being used to bring
bring him in do you got it like actively
which we know I was using to let him in
before when he was pressing now it's
going to be used to bring him in you
guys understand that okay now uh so he's
he's going to pull and like that's in my
shoulder and here I go boom and then I
do the movement
[Music]
sh okay
just like before you're going to because
I'm telling you even though I explained
it before and you had some insight this
is a
higher a less tolerant environment
meaning it's going to trigger
whoa no keep the mind dropping release
and do the pattern okay do do you guys
understand just like if when you push
harder it's going to trigger the
dichotomous mus
more okay so you can use that to
increase your skill at releasing and
this is likely going to in trigger that
mind more so you can increase your skill
more because even though we said it's
not you still
seeing
dichotomy in the in the pressure drill
do you got it okay let's try it see what
we get pull the shoulder pull the
shoulder pull the
shoulder
one
more so to pull the shoulder you got to
disconnect it you got to you got to get
it out of that bracing posture
almost and the elbow
[Music]
better so I I I want you know as I take
my UK is I want them to feel what I'm
doing so I'm showing other
people but I'm mainly training the UK or
something
okay and
so I go I go fast so they can feel and
be hungry for what the was that do
you see um but it's not a matter of
going fast cuz you you can go fast and
you're like back in the dichotomous mind
okay so she's going to pull oh that's
what I don't want yeah you're fine okay
keep pulling and then you're going to
see where I do something different okay
and then I move my elbow you're still
pulling I keep moving my shoulder can
you see my shoulder going back right
keep moving it keep moving
it okay she's pulling again go ahead and
pull and that's what I don't want keep
pulling I'm going to change it there it
is keep pulling and I move my
for
e
okay would you say you were pulling yeah
okay uh so you could do do it this way
and I I she goes I want you to say oh no
keep going cuz I'm going change that
relationship even though that hands way
out there I'll change the relationship
then the elbow the shoulder is going to
go
first pull pull pull keep pulling the
shoulder you pull again go ahead pull
that that's not I don't want don't
doesn't matter that I'm here it doesn't
matter cuz from here I can change the
relationship
pull pull pull pull your
harest
good
e
okay let me
uh point out something okay so when I
was with Maya and and when I with Taylor
and I said yeah okay feel this and then
as I started talking he could tell the
sensation is changing
okay uh what is the difference is the
mind the mind is dropping
okay it's drops from releasing it and
right so the skill is releasing as I
release I learn what that is you can
Define it that way what does releasing
mean uh releasing is when the Mind drops
releasing is when the Yang aspect is
internalized okay um you can also
say that um that's where I become
permeable so he can push from here you
can push from here push and pull are no
longer are no longer relevant Etc okay
in O sense's tradition of aoto that
permeability
is wherein they would practice their
possession rights okay so and this is a
common uh practice in premodern
Technologies s is you bring the Divine
into you
okay so you're permeable so the Divine
can come into you in an energetic system
uh Heaven Yi is heaven Chi so Heaven Chi
can come into you okay you still have to
be
permeable
um that initial skill of release in my
opinion it's more
important
that you do it with as little
[Music]
little uh input from you as
possible okay so I say for
example uh I don't I don't cause or make
the ego tripartite mind
stop I release and it stops
okay um I release and Y Chi enters me I
don't bring y Chi into me okay th those
are natural workings of the universe
that happen how by taking out my agency
okay taking out
myself if I seek it it's not you you
can't it's not going to happen okay
these are passive
receptive uh things that happen so the
Holy Spirit comes into you you can't
bring it into you in other words okay so
you have a possession right you don't
you you set yourself up meaning you make
yourself permeable and the Kami comes
into you
okay so I'm more a fan that if you look
at our cooku drills and our IE drills
level one is the beginning and the end
and both level one in both drill sets is
no movement and just drop which is what
I'm
describing when I told him do okay do
you feel that all right do you feel this
okay or when I had Maya leaning over and
I said pull and I go okay do you feel
that I'm going to change the
relationship that's where the dropping
happened
okay what you're doing and so that's
where your training should be returning
to all the time as much as possible
because even though you're moving it's
at the beginning of the movement and
what you're trying to do is maintain
that throughout movement
okay that
said in your
Kon you want and this again a scholar of
religion here this is my take on all
these cultures that are doing
this your hand
movements
are
um meant to
manipulate that natural process that
happens okay when you learn to release
and then the natural process of the mind
dropping or the ego tripartite mind
ceasing in its
dominance when or when the lower tomen
forms that's a natural process that just
happens once you release
okay the hand movements are manipulation
of that process
okay it's just so human right we're like
okay that's the natural ersing but I
think I can't improve it I think I can
get it better um I don't think you can
but that is what you're doing okay so
your patterns are uh all
about accentuating that dropping but
only if I'm training in this
way if I'm not training this way you
will not only see that the mind is up
high but you will see the arm patterns
change
because they're not following what the
mind is
dropping in a way to accentuate the mind
dropping okay so for
example uh we'll just go back to the
spinal
displacement I go and then you go and
then I'm going to
throw and my hand is up you see that is
not the p pattern the pattern to
complete is down here and that
dness is the mind dropping at the end
okay which is why in aido you have your
pins and it's down here the Mind drops
stays dropped at the end
okay so I stay in that mind State and I
am moving with my
hands this this Chi this alchemically
treated Yang chi in my body inside my
lower ton den and I'm moving
that so if you pay attention
now alchemically yongi comes in and it
goes down hits the Earth y Yin is
generated and I start spinning them okay
because to return to the pre-
dichotomous State the only way you do it
is spiral rotating so if you watch my
hands you can see I'm bringing it in you
see it's coming into me that's where UK
comes forward right and I'm starting to
turn it so in I'm on the top of it now
and I'm turning it around this way okay
I now bring it in again more and I come
underneath pom and then I now
end the ritual with the drop the final
drop of the mine
okay so probably unnoticeable but if you
come over here
Sean and I'll demonstrate that on this
hand so the energy is coming in oh bring
it in I go over the top of it boom
underneath it drop it okay watch if you
watch my other
hand right and I'm leave it to my own
you're going to you're going to see the
other hand starts to keep it keep it
moving it's not dead I'm not here one
arm
fighting do you guys understand so my
whole body is doing it in look in
in
turn
wash the other hand push your hardest
okay
okay and I'm just moving that stuff
around
okay got it all right bring your other
hand in now that we have enough
awareness of what the the hand we're
working on is trying to do okay here we
go